hey friends what's up I'm Alana and
welcome to my youtube channel for those
who don't know I am an Australian and
I've been living in the US for a year
and a half in total now I live in
California for six months I lived in San
Jose and now for nine months I've been
living in San Francisco and in that time
I want that there is a lot more of a
language barrier than I thought that was
of course there was that everyone knows
a different like an American trunk is an
Australian boot but there are loads of
other things that I had no idea were
different so I've been writing a list of
them that I thought I would tell you
guys so the first one account of an
American counter is a bench in Australia
so I'm referring to a kitchen bench or a
kitchen counter it's the surface in a
kitchen I found this one out in a pretty
weird way where I told someone that I
had left something on the kitchen bench
they were like what we don't have a
bench in the kitchen because a bench in
America pretty much blanket just means
like a park bench in America
bangs of what we call in Australia a
fringe that is this pot of my head that
this stuff all this front bit that's a
fringe now I'm not entirely sure about
this bangs may just mean like a straight
cut fringe but I'm pretty sure that it
means any kind of layers around your
face not entirely sure
in which case Australia this part is the
fringe and like all of this stuff that I
have gone on here would just be layers I
guess a hot dog in America is a kind of
sausage this one really weirds me out so
in Australia a hot dog is like the whole
package you have the sausage the bread
and like the mustard and the ketchup as
well the whole combination is a hot dog
also ketchup in Australia is called
tomato sauce also tomato sauce in
Australia is called pasta sauce or
spaghetti sauce to translate that
backwards for the Australians watching
they call tomato sauce ketchup and they
call pasta sauce the kind of stuff that
you put on your spaghetti tomato sauce
so in America a hotdog is both the
combination of all of the things and the
specific kind of sausage that goes in
the hotdog so that the singular piece of
meat is referred to as a
dog I'm not a fan of this one because
it's like if you ask someone to give you
a hot dog how do they know if you also
want the bread and the mustard and the
ketchup or if you just want the sausage
they don't who knows what you're gonna
get handed a cooler in America is an
esky in Australia so that's the kind of
a plastic bin thing that you put ice in
and then put your drinks in to keep it
cool we call that an esky the cooler
makes a lot more sense a beer koozie in
America is called a stubby cooler or
stubby holder so that's like the kind of
synthetic pouch thing that you might put
your beer in a fall paper
this one's a fun one so I work one day I
needed to print something or get a size
for something and I asked if we had any
eighth wall paper nobody really knew
what I meant
a4 is the standard paper size there's
also a two paper a1 paper
a5 paper and that's how we refer to
paper sizes in Australia it's like the
standard paper size is a4 in America I
think that they refer to it by the
inches and it still says a4 size on some
of the packets you can order off paper
in America but they just don't refer to
as stats it's pretty weird swimming
trunks in America togs in Australia gas
in America is petrol in Australia like a
lot of people probably know this but one
of the weirdest conversations I've ever
had here was like I said something along
the lines of I need to go down to the
petrol station and get a litre of petrol
they just had no idea what I meant so I
think it here it's called a gas station
and you get gas and it is in gallons not
leaders math in America is maths in
Australia so if you're talking about the
subject of mathematics in Australia we
say it with the S on the end so it's
maths in America it's just called math
if this is you know very small
difference but people still laughed at
me when I said it and I find this one
kind of funny like it's not mathematic
it's the study of mathematics
where is the ass a twin or a full-sized
bed in America you can call it either
twin awful is a double bed in a shredded
a power outlet in America is a power
point in Australia discover this one by
walking into a meeting room at walk and
saying are there any power points in you
and people assume that you are referring
to a power point like the software power
outlet makes perfect sense
I feel like power point also makes sense
feel like the thing that doesn't make
sense here is why a PowerPoint
presentation is actually called a
PowerPoint presentation this next one is
just a pronunciation one in America they
say apricot for what we call an apricot
in Australia there's office stuff like
this that I already knew about so it
didn't wake me out like uh aluminium
being aluminium he does a few others but
apricot I did not know so the first time
someone said apricot I just had no idea
what they were talking about a biscuit
in America this one really [ __ ] me up
is like a scone or a scone in Australia
biscuit in Australia is like a cookie is
a type of biscuit cookie is that the
kind that has like chips in it that have
different flavors like a chocolate chip
cookie
so a biscuit includes all of those kinds
of sweets like an Oreo is a type of
biscuit a Tim Tam is a type of biscuit
but in America it's like a kind of
doughy bready thing like a scum and I
was so confused the first time I
encountered this I was driving home with
a friend who was very drunk and we were
going through McDonald's drive-thru and
he asked for a sausage with biscuit or
something like that we definitely don't
have this at McDonald's in Australia
because that doesn't make any sense it
was like you were asking for like a
sweet like kind of cookie
with sausage naturally all made more
sense when you got a weird doughy
breading kind of thing but that I had no
idea that was said differently and it
really confused me a particularly funny
one
the phrase puffed I really found this
out last week uh if you all puffed in
Australia it's like out of breath and
last but not least is a toasty in
America it's called the grilled cheese
in Australia we call it a toasty or
grilled cheese either is fine but
I particularly like the phrase toasty
because it's put toasted cheese sandwich
but yeah that's still a sofa from a year
and a half of being here I'm sure there
are variations of all of these kinds of
things across different states in both
Australia and America this is just based
on stuff that I haven't counted and I
kind of love it I look forward to
encountering more weird stuff and that
is it for me today everyone I'm Alana I
will see you guys next time
Oh